ah what happened what oMG your eyelashes
are so long I love it
thank you sir like a butterfly in the
sky Wow my god is butterfly do you hear
did you hear ya heard the u.s. is
looking at banning tick tock and other
Chinese social media because they're
spying on us
what the [ __ ] am I gonna do at 4:00 in
the morning till 8:00 a.m. oh that's
that prime tick-tock hour yeah yeah yeah
how about sleep [ __ ] with Trump's
that's what a lot of people are thinking
right now
yeah because that'd be [ __ ] hilarious
ticket are you doing so many yeah no
funny I forgot it okay pop people do
terrifying another big thing that tick
collars are doing right now - is that
they're like going into like the Trump
website and putting things into their
cart to [ __ ] with the system numbers
$20,000 worth of stuff you guys are so
smart I love him why are really smart
it's just because he's me ad is he is he
upset well this is what
the Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said
that the u.s. is looking at Benny's
banning Chinese social media apps and so
he said that this that they're taking it
very seriously I want to create dich
doch and then we'll just take it over it
just sounds like takes off with a
Vietnamese person because Nick Falzone I
thought it's about dicks no so Mike said
quote if you want your private
information in the hands of the Chinese
Communist Party then download yeah okay
so as Mike talked can I can I ask
something really quick at arias thanking
this is Providence
no Mike Pompeo oh I see I mean I don't
know if I'm dumb I probably am but my
mom doesn't really care because I don't
really have anything that value that's
how I feel the thing I do feel bad for
other people that having millions of
father the to log on the bill
you guys know anonymous right yeah
anonymous love them great we love them
great group yeah um so they said this
tick tock is harvesting data on children
/ teens to monitor their market reach
and political development to find the
best mythology's to coerce them within
the next five to ten years also this
gets China an upper hand on manipulating
large swathes of society across several
countries which is by the way already
happening right now based off of a
former KGB he did a freaking interview
in the 80s and it's been on YouTube
since seven years ago or whatever I
watched this a while back but he was
saying like basically the KGB had a plan
on how to disrupt the American public
and you know during the Cold War they
were trying to get people more into
communism so you know they infiltrated
our universities our school clubs
promoted all the different activist
groups that were more communist leaning
and then just like the same way as the
US government goes into other countries
and promote you know more US friendly
clubs and groups and you know dictators
or whatever Russia did that too and then
for them
there were like even though they are no
longer the Soviet Union and they changed
their like they changed politically but
their agenda of dismantling American
society still kept going so that's why
there's there's huge yeah
like okay so if you guys watch this
Facebook documentary that they did I
forgot the name of it but we need the
name Joe I forgot it but but inside
there there's they proved our Facebook
this is why Zuckerberg was going through
all this [ __ ] is because Russia
created with their troll farms we all
know that they exist they made to
Facebook groups right one was like a
super right-wing nationalist group in
Texas and one was like suit no it was
super
radical Muslim right and then so within
these two groups they decided to have a
rally on the same day and then they
coordinated a protest and in our law
enforcement got ahead of it and they're
just like oh [ __ ] we can't let this go
down because these two groups might go
into a violent but it was the same
people it was Russia
that's office to fake ones and in the up
group people who are married becomes the
real thing yeah I identify with that and
then they set it up so they're looking
for like Nazi guys or guys that might
want to be a white supremacist and then
they build this group and then they're
looking for like maybe guys that like
Isis or like violent groups on that side
and then they try to bring them together
in one day so they'll fight yeah and
this was already happening in the mid to
early 2000s right and in our last
election it was hella crazy yeah so like
with that I can totally see how if
Russia's doing that I'm pretty [ __ ]
sure China's doing that because when I
was going to college and this was like
in 2000 [ __ ] seven right on our
school newspaper they found out that we
had Chinese spies in our community call
over I remember that okay so but the
child the idea of a spy is not like a
government agent double of seven is
right according information back there's
a lot of it have a tiny gun okay there's
a lot of there's a lot of data for
losers smiling you're boring dude no but
there's data farmers and so what they'll
do is like let's say your exchange
student and then the government will
approach you and be like okay every
three months we want information we're
just gonna call you up you're like all
right so what's going on and they'll be
like yeah you know the kids here let's
say like they're me up they gave me a
wedgie they told me if I go is a China
Center high like I don't know what's
going on here you had to get information
and they just talked about American
community society the sentiment whatever
because they're looking for ways to
cause issues we cuz if we're fighting
each other within then it's less issues
for them
in the country worldwide exactly now
what was that thing that um I think dad
was telling us there was this like piece
of literature that was printed out in
like 58 or 59 where it's pretty much
promoting the fact that that communism
is here in America and it's like
infiltrated it literally gave like steps
oh yeah first you got to do this
dismantle this and then which then leads
to dismantling this and eventually
America will fold in you know like now
we're getting rid of all the statues and
now people don't want to celebrate 4th
of July and then like civil unrest it's
like the major thing and then oh and
also like devaluing religion and like
pretty much a lot of these days are not
very religious that much and then there
were so many it was like a long list all
checked out [ __ ] all of these things
what happened over the years yeah it's
the list big enough where it's just like
ok yeah of course it's gonna be the list
because it's such an extensive list I
know it's it's pretty specific sure it's
very specific and it's like step by step
like first you have to do this and then
in the leads to the next I mean they had
like a whole bunch of like this is gonna
happen and then this is gonna happen
this and this was printed out like way
before any of the things that they wrote
even happen there was like predictions
of what's gonna happen in the country of
America in order to get closer to being
a communist country so tick tock is
basically just conditioning children to
China number one I mean it's it's every
social media platform you can argue that
right it's like every single social
media platform their biggest thing is
collecting information yeah like now
either sell the information off to
marketers who use that for marketing
tactics or politicians who use that for
you know political advances so like even
like the whole thing behind tik-tok
attacking Trump's campaign stuff by
reserving stuff that messes with their
numbers because they want to use those
numbers to see who else they can target
ads to you know so the whole everybody's
doing it it's just whoever is like
they're not what are they using that
anymore
yeah it's all data farming do that so
true cuz of i was i almost worked with
this one company and with this one
company i was gonna be creating
something and
like they were telling me the back end
of it and they were pretty much like
they had this app kind of thing and the
app ins of collecting certain
information about the user that which
then will better help like per uh sell
certain things to these people and I was
just like wait weird and then the person
that was like oh this is like comment
like almost every app does it Facebook
Instagram all of them you just no [ __ ]
like that
well they're a billion dollar bought and
evaluated but they were a famous
subscription company right and they were
actually not making any [ __ ] money
but they had so much data on people that
they were dating subscriptions for
Westworld man that they sold for a
billion dollars info that's how much
info and data is hella that's why I'm
like if another country has it and
they're trying to destroy society I'm
not for it but for me it's like yeah
there is a privacy and all that but then
if it's just like companies learning
market research cell-to-cell uh that's
not as harmful because it doesn't have
this intent of like it's greedy but it's
not dangerous like how do we destroy
their society because that's what
competing nations do like we do that to
other countries right so we we like for
example like Libya is a country that we
came into we armed the terrorist groups
there we caused a lot of turmoil and we
dismantled their government and now
there's like a country that had the
highest literacy rate in Africa and a
lot of stability economic stability in
that region we destroyed that country
and we destroyed that area and no one
talks about this or knows about this
right but we commonly do this we as in
America we you know basically look for
weaknesses or we see a minority group
that might be getting picked on by the
majority and then we call [ __ ] in that
country by funding these group
ammunition whatever giving them us
military training whatever we do all
that [ __ ] and that's basically how like
the cartels and stuff has came up to
because we trained those guys so it's
like if we're doing this to other
countries what makes you think they're
not doing that to us if they know like
there's a group here that needs support
or whatever and they have a lot of
resentment toward this country they're
gonna support the [ __ ] out of them
instead of banning tik-tok they should
utilize the kpop fan power you know
China's doing bad stuff and then they'll
take down [ __ ] dude imagine if the whole
country was let ran like a kpop fan
group in a kdrama well they went from
tic-tock tic-tock spokesperson said are
they Chinese so this is what they said
don't worry we just want mommy
tik-tok is led by an American CEO with
hundreds of employees and key leaders
across safety security product and
public policy here in the US we have no
higher priority than promoting a safe
and secure app experience for our users
we have never provided user data to the
Chinese government nor would we do so if
asked yeah but then the Chinese
government never comes out and says hey
we're Chinese government we want data
they're gonna be a [ __ ] China
marketing international group right like
what analytic yeah we're we're Chinese
like marketing pop stars or whatever
right and then they come in and they're
like let's buy your data like the [ __ ]
and then who what are they ever gonna
come out and be like yes you guys caught
us never I mean I think their big
argument was like we're unlike any other
American company we have data on
American soil and in the backups in like
Singapore
so they're like if anything you know
every any other company can be like
taken like their data is gonna be taken
by China - that's true
who knows that's their yeah
[Music]
[Music]